[Musique]
vous pensez entendre le dernier titre de
mariah carey mais il y aurait pas comme
un écho là
[Musique]
non
et oui cela fait bientôt 20 ans que
chaque année mariah carey nous ressort
son tube de noël il n'y a que la robe
qui change
et pour cause avec plus de 12 millions
d'exemplaires écoulés il contribue à
faire d'elle la plus grosse vendeuse de
disques des années 90 grâce à ce titre
la diva s'est offert une maison à côté
de new york d'une valeur de 25 millions
de dollars
mariah carey n'est pas la seule à s'en
mettre plein les poches au moment des
fêtes
michael bublé a vendu 5 millions
d'albums christina aguilera 3 millions
et même le chouchou des adolescentes
justin bieber s'y est mis c'est vraiment
un exercice de style là bas quelle que
soit son style justement rapeurs rockers
ou fan de country et bien l'artiste fait
son album de noël
c'est après guerre que la mode est
lancée aux états unis
frank sinatra avec white christmas est
rapidement suivi par elvis presley
depuis tout le monde s'y met même les
bad boys ce qui donne un mélange des
genres assez insolite
alors comment ce business profitent ils
aux stars les albums de noël se
retrouveront-ils en masse sous le sapin
cette année je suis pas tirer sur les
chansons sur les reprises de chansons de
noël spécialement non non c'est pas
quelque chose qui me plaît spécialement
fait massacrer si je mets les chants de
noël donc si les consommateurs font la
fine bouche
il ya pourtant un tube de noël 100 %
made in france qui s'écoule encore à
300000 exemplaires chaque année dit pas
non
quand tu descendras du ciel
le tube de tino rossi et le single le
plus vendu en france depuis sa sortie en
1946 mais malgré ce succès peu
d'artistes francophones ont tenté
l'exercice
et il ya une raison à cela aux etats
unis noël se prépare dès septembre
alors qu'en france la magie du réveillon
ne dure que quelques semaines c'est ce
que nous explique antoine louis fiant
responsable marketing dans une grande
maison de disques
lorsque vous avez trois quatre mois pour
proposer un projet auprès du grand
public vous pouvez véritablement
proposer un véritable album avec des
nouvelles chansons des nouvelles
compositions
parce que vous avez un laps de temps
pour pouvoir le le travail et le propose
au public le commercialiser le
promouvoir qui beaucoup plus grand que
si vous avez uniquement trois semaines
ici en france on a seulement trois
semaines on arrive quand même à créer du
business
les ventes de disques augmente de 30 %
sur cette période le secret des artistes
sortir des réédition de leur album ou
des coffrets collector c'est l'occasion
pour les maisons de disques pour les
artistes de proposer quelque chose qui
est qu'ils fassent véritablement cadeaux
pas uniquement l'album en tant que tel
qu'on peut trouver toute l'année mais
vraiment un produit qui a été pensé pour
les fêtes de fin d'année
tous les poids lourds de la chanson
française sont en tête de gondole mylène
farmer ou encore johnny mais l'album qui
cartonne en ce moment c'est celui là
[Musique]
génération goldman auquel participe m
pokora étals se vend comme des petits
pains cent trente mille albums écoulés
en à peine deux semaines
et pourtant ce ne sont que des reprises
peut-être que stratégie marketing
en tout cas je pense que c'est bien pour
les relais pour nour et louis pour les
fêtes pour les gens qui y est diamond
star du moment
l'album est un cadeau potentiel c'est
une période forcément qui est propice
pour sortir un album aussi une stratégie
commerciale poussé à l'excès chez
certains regardez ces pochette de
l'album de noël de michael bublé entre
2011 et 2012
la seule différence est la couleur du
tea ses vrais couverts ses chroniqueurs
musique pour lui les fêtes de noël c'est
l'occasion de faire du neuf avec du
vieux
mais il a compris que finalement c'était
son créneau et ça ne lâchera pas michael
mais on en bouffe rana tous les
réveillons
la star a quand même composé trois
inédits pour ce nouvel album et on ne
doute pas qu'ils travaillent également
sa nouvelle chorégraphie
[Musique]
noël permet aussi de ressusciter
certaines stars disparu de nos écrans
cette année la palme de l'album le plus
commercial revient sans doute à the
christmas de john travolta et olivia
newton john bien sûr que ça marche à
tous les coups quand même moi je trouve
que c'est quand même une vague fini
story ça reste quand même très très
marketing pour le coup on n'est pas sur
une dimension artistique où les deux
messieurs autolog comme près de veut me
faire croire qu'ils croient à la
chrétienté au petit papa noël en france
sortir un album de noël est très risqué
mais taylor précise ont peut-être trouvé
la parade
ce groupe de sept chanteurs de gospel
mélange a cappella les reprises de
grands classiques français et
anglo-saxons
[Musique]
ça me permettait de créer ce lien aussi
avec cette culture qu'on a qu'on
affectionne particulièrement et puis
aussi la culture française avec des
chants de noël qui sont bien ancrées
aussi un culture française
le groupe s'est entouré d'artistes
reconnus comme julie zenatti sans doute
pour toucher un plus large public
et devinez quelle chanson ils reprennent
[Musique]
reste à savoir si les françaises seront
réceptifs et cette tradition venue des
états unis
en tout cas sachez que pour noël les
artistes ont bien pensé à vous alors on
souhaite un joyeux noël à 100% mag
oui oui mais joyeux noël 100% mag